the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen-only mode
good morning everyone and welcome to
investor exposure for the 26th of March
today we are having a great lineup of
four speakers field Michael Walters Todd
harvest rate and Matthew
Buckley this session will be recorded
and sent to your email please take a
look at your GoToWebinar control panel
into the questions box you will be able
to ask any questions you want
during this speakers presentation I
would like to begin and bring to the
show our first get unmuted Michael
Walters welcome good morning Michael hi
Anna good morning how are you uh pretty
good pretty good yes a safe stay strong
crazy timing for us today well today
I'll be talking about you know the way
the markets have been pretty chaotic
recently so you know they seem to be
moving around very fast so I'll be
talking about reversals and how to see
them in the order flow and I think it'll
be a nice timely presentation for
everybody sounds good to me
I will give screen over to you and get
back to you around 8:45 Pacific okay
great let me see okay hopefully you can
see my screen okay
you
all right everybody today I'll be
talking about order flow and reversal
trading and I feel it's very important
in these times you know when markets are
very chaotic to sort of have a way to
see what's happening in the market very
easily with the order flow and what I'll
show you is two setups that I like to
look for in the order flow you know
they're not fancy setups you know you
don't need to do any draw any lines or
do any major calculation it's nothing
like that you know order flow is
basically reading what the market is
telling you if you stick around to the
end I'm gonna give you a copy of my book
if you don't already have it called
trading order flow it's a digital
download so you'll just have to enter
your email to get it so you're not gonna
be sent a hard copy cover of the book
but before I begin you know a brief
disclaimer please understand that
trading is risky I'm sure everybody
understands that by now the way the
markets have sold off quite dramatically
in the last month and you know only
trade with money you can afford to lose
and those of you that are new to order
flow and new to who I am just a brief
description of who I am my name is
Michael Balto's and I've been in the
market since the 1990s I started on the
CMA floor as a runner with Dean Witter
and eventually I left the floor when
electronic trading started taking off I
joined the upstairs trading desk and I
spent about three years total at Dean
Witter then I left for EDF man which is
a English trading company on their
global macro desk
I joined after that I joined Commerce
Bank the big German bank as their your
ex trader and after that it was right
after 9/11 I left there and took about
six months off and you know just sort of
had to refine find myself again and I
joined Cargill I was a trading desk
manager in Chicago and eventually I get
sent out to Singapore to set up a
trading desk there and after a Cargill I
joined JP Morgan where I spent eight
years as vice president of the Futures
Trading and in 2013 I left JP Morgan and
you know I just started trading for
myself this time and eventually I
started my software company order flows
dot-com so
you know when I left JPMorgan I really
wanted to have a contribution to the
trading world so I started writing the
book right trading order flow and I was
trading for my own account I was using a
software from another company and it was
just basic order flow software you know
telling you with the volume trader on
the bid volume traded on the offer and I
wanted more from the software right I
wanted the software to show me more of
what was happening in the market by
doing the analysis that I was doing by
hand doing in my hair in my head and I
met with the programmer and I said you
know what this is how I analyze the
markets right can you put this into the
software so you know we started working
together and about six months later we
came up with the order flows trader
software and and initially it was just
for me you know I created it just for my
own trading but then I just showed more
and more people there saying hey you
know can I get a copy of that and
eventually that's how order flows com
was born and the charts that are used in
this presentation are generated from my
order foolish trader which runs on ninja
trader 8 ok so I work with a lot of
traders in the past and I've always you
know they show me their charts and
sometimes it just looks like they're
throwing noodles at the wall you know
there's so many lines it's just like you
know they'll be like well the market
reacted off of this price here then I
reacted here but it's like there's
there's no sense to it because they got
lines pretty much you know every 5
points so sooner or later you know you
know like even a broken clock is Right
twice a day right you need some
structure in your trading and order flow
you know gives a lot of traders
structure and I prefer to keep trading
as simple as possible
I like to look at price and volume over
time or over a range you know most
traders only look at price they don't
take into account the volume now if
you've ever studied economics or you've
run a small business you'll understand
the importance of volume right when you
do your numbers you know whether you're
making money or losing money you're
gonna check how much you're selling at a
certain price or you just don't say well
I sold I sell milk at you know $2 a
gallon well you know I so this amount of
milk it
a gallon I saw this amount at a dollar
90 I sell this much at two dollars and
ten you know you find the area where you
can maximize your profits that's why
volume is important because it helps you
understand the current supply and demand
situation now most recently right we're
all familiar with this right the whole
panic buying of toilet paper and you
know this is pictures I took myself in
the grocery stores over time because you
know I sort of saw this coronavirus
thing coming back in January because I
had my sister-in-law from Asia was here
and she was trying to get her flight
back to Asia back to the Philippines and
she and she's having a hard time
changing it because she didn't want to
travel through Shanghai then I just sort
of noticed you know what was happening
people were starting to buy stuff well
all of a sudden now demand was hitting
the market for toilet paper right but
the price of toilet paper was consistent
but the demand was outsized everyone was
buying it but if everyone is buying what
do you think is gonna happen well it's
going to eventually every all the volume
the amount of toilet paper is going to
be gone if demand you know the price is
steady but demand is still there now
another good example all right I have
three kids I buy a lot of antibac soft
soap okay and normally I go to Walmart
and buy it for 397 for a 50 ounce
container alright and I usually keep you
know three or four anyway in the house
because you know I'll buy it when
there's a coupon in the paper for a
dollar off but now you can't even buy it
at Walmart you go to ebay it's 30
dollars right so it's the supply and
demand you know now personally I think
you know these people that are price
gouging you know should be getting a
knock on their door from the authorities
but you know that that's a perfect
example of supply and demand right and
you can see how it applies in the
grocery business but the same thing
applies in the markets right markets go
up on increased demand markets will go
down on increased supply when supply and
demand are equal soft soap is three
dollars and 97 with the Manda's high
soft soap is now 30 dollars
but how does this apply to you as a
trainer right if you can spot an area
where very aggressive buyers are
stepping in at low prices you know
people coming in buying all the soft
soap people buying all the toilet paper
that's your opportunity to get in and
buy right or we haven't seen this in the
grocery store but very aggressive
sellers coming in and selling at high
prices but you see you're seeing it at
you know eBay not so much on Amazon
anymore you know people we've got a lot
of soft soap they got a lot of supply
they're offering it out there at you
know $30 you know people go hey I'll bid
$30 they hit those bids so how can you
tell if aggressive traders are
especially active is your going to look
for imbalances in the market now to look
for a market imbalance you need to look
at the volume that's being traded and
you know this is but you know we know
that the market trades in a two way
auction right there's a bid price
there's an offer price there's a
quantity on the bid there's a quantity
on the offer okay so you know if the
market is currently 29 55 and a quarter
bid offered at 55 and a half size of 72
by 196 for the market to tick up someone
has to buy the 55 and a half for the
market to start ticking down someone as
it starts selling the 55 and a quarters
once they sell all the 55 and a quarters
the next bid is 55 once people sell
those out the next bid is 54 and 3/4 now
once you understand that the markets
move in a two way auction you have to
understand there's two types of traders
and their activities and depending on
your trading style and order type you
are one or the other now a passive
trader is a trader who tries to buy on
the bid or sell on the offer they wait
for the market to come to them okay so
if you are trading the market you put a
bid in the market whether it's on the
current bid or it's five dollars lower
you're considered a passive trader
you're waiting for the market to come to
you if you get filled great if you don't
you know it's not the end of the world
now an aggressive trader is someone that
doesn't wait for the market to come to
them they trade at the mark
they sell into the bid or buy the offer
they do a market order basically you
know so they see the market is offered
at fifty five and three-quarters
you know they buy the fifty five and
three-quarters they want to get in the
market they want to get in now and an
imbalance occurs when in the 2a auction
you compare the volume that was traded
on the bid versus the volume that was
traded on the offer if the volume traded
on the offer is greater than the volume
traded on the bid by four to one again
four to one is a guideline some people
use three to one other people use ten to
one but most traders prefer four to one
you would consider that a buying
imbalance and vice-versa for selling a
balance so if the volume traded on the
bid versus the volume traded on the
offer is four times more volume traded
on the bid meaning you got four times as
many traders selling at the market
selling into the bid as opposed to
buying the offer then you would have a
selling imbalance you have more
aggressive sellers so how can you see it
well some people say well I see traders
say they like to put up the time and
sales window on their screen and
honestly the way the market moves is
it's so fast you know this is last night
this is about 8:15 just before 8:15 p.m.
and you can see you know it's a lot of
ones and basically a lot of ones this is
Nasdaq right every trade it was going
through is basically uh one lot and if
you're trying to you know make sense of
this it's imagine during the day it is
moving so fast you can't keep up with it
now other traders they like to look at a
dome okay like a price ladder and see
you know the volume traded on the bid
volume traded on the offer the problem
is the dome moves very fast under normal
market conditions and when I say normal
market conditions you know I'm talking
about you know one of the vixx's you
know below ten you know if you're
watching the Nasdaq Dome during the day
you know you're talking about a market
that is you know two three points wide
not two or three ticks two or three
points and it's moving so fast up and
down you can't
SNPs is a little bit more stable crude
oil is a bit stable your currency is
also generally a bit stable so again it
depends on the market but to watch a
dome you got to know what to look for
and honestly you know trying to
interpret the dome or the time in sales
you know is like you got to be like Rain
Man or the guy in hangover or you got to
do all these quick calculations in your
head but you know what I want to show
with you and I want to share with you is
the easier way to watch order flow and
that's called the footprint chart okay
and you can see the imbalances on a
footprint chart because it'll be
highlighted to you okay after it happens
you know you don't have to be trying to
catch up with a dome you know staring at
the dome intently that you know if you
look away for a split second you miss
something right at least the footprint
chart keeps it all in a nice easy to
read format the selling imbalances will
be the red numbers inside of a bar the
blue numbers would be a buying imbalance
inside the bar and what you see on a
footprint chart is you see the volume at
each price level what was traded on the
bid what was traded on the offer
now remember it's a two-way auction so
you're going to compare it diagonally
not horizontally and you're gonna be
looking for those areas of the
imbalances the imbalances measure the
two-way auction and looking for
imbalances between what was traded on
the bid versus what was traded on the
offer so you know imagine taking all the
data you see going through on a time and
sales window you know if you don't
believe me open up a time and sales
window on your trading system and see if
you can make heads or tails of it you
know it's just gonna give you a headache
take a look at the dome okay and if
you've watched a dome for long enough
you know that if you get up to go grab a
drink in the refrigerator come back you
just you missed all that information you
know it's gone right you're not gonna
see it again but the footprint chart
puts it into an easy to read format that
allows you to make quick and easy
trading decisions and you're not going
to see any of that information on a bar
chart now there's a lot of information
you know a lot of people get scared when
they look at an order flow chart the
first time because they see a lot of
numbers people are scared of numbers
but believe me is there's nothing to be
scared of in fact once you understand
what the numbers are that you're looking
at it just makes perfect sense you know
it's a nice addition to everybody's way
of trading so this is a e-mini
one-minute chart and you know each bar
I'm sorry it's a 30-second chart and you
can see the volume traded in each bar
you can see you know where there are
imbalances where there's support and
resistance where there's aggressive
buyers you can see the delta which is a
difference between net buyers and
sellers in a bar I'm not gonna be
talking about that today but that helps
you determine you know when there's
shifts in supply and demand point of
control each bar has a point of control
as the volume level it's the price level
with the most volume and there's going
to be times where it acts as support and
resistance and imbalances right it's the
volume in a bar in the two-way auction
where the volume traded on the bid
versus the offer is greater than four to
one now you know when I try to explain
order flow to people the easiest way to
tell the describe it is like this
imagine playing poker but being able to
see the cards of the other players right
when you're looking at a footprint chart
you're seeing what everybody else in the
market has just done in the market you
can see you know if people bought at bad
prices if people sold at bad prices you
know if someone's defending a price area
and that's very important information if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
you're not going to see that information
okay so this was yesterday in the e
minis this is a 30 second bar the
candlestick chart you know I would show
a one minute chart people say why you
looking at 30 seconds and not one minute
well honestly the market is so volatile
recently that looking at a one minute
chart is kind of difficult because
there's just so much information going
through so fast you know I just take it
down a level
I look at a 30 second chart but you can
see right there's you know there's
there's three potential reversal areas
number one number two number three you
know you got the red candle you know any
time the market is going up and you get
a red candle
you know bar closing lower than where it
opened it's a potential reversal all
right so you got one two and three one
day
really workout you mean sold off a
little bit number two just one sideways
number three you had the nice you know
the nice 30 point sell-off but if you're
if you're looking at you know one two
and three you know I know some people
would sell a number one I know some
people that would sell number two I know
some people that would sell number three
but if you're looking at the order flow
you wouldn't sell number one it wouldn't
sell number two you would sell number
three okay and how can you determine
that is because you're gonna be looking
at the imbalances in the bar you know
are there aggressive sellers coming into
the market so a number 1 this is number
one on the footprint chart you don't see
any selling imbalances or you see no red
numbers in the bar number two you see
one sound imbalance
okay that's good but that's it right but
if you look at number three
you've got three sound imbalances right
and you know with order flow three is
sort of like the magic number that you
know a lot of traders look for in terms
of imbalances or stacked imbalances
right and you can see you got a swing
high right just as two and one we're
swing highs but you don't have the
aggressive selling coming in in the bar
number three all right you've got one
two three sound imbalances now my
software like I said earlier right I
created my software to help me see
things in the order flow that I might
otherwise miss my software will put a
pink box around a bar that has three or
more selling imbalances for a Down
candle a red candle or three or more
buying a balances for a green candle now
this differs then your normal stacked
imbalance where you have three or more
buying and balances stacked neatly on
top of each other that's what this green
area is or stacks on a balance what you
see here and this red candle in the
middle three or more it's on a balance
is stacked neatly on top of each other
but what I'm saying is when you have
three or more imbalances in a bar that
is still important right and it's
important to notice when that happens if
you're just looking for stacked
imbalances you're going to miss the bars
that have three or more imbalances
imbalances in them as well and why is
that important what is you can see on
the bar and the high you've got through
three imbalances two of them are stacked
neatly on top of each other then there's
one that's not a selling imbalance it's
26 against 67 then you have another
selling imbalance so you know it's just
one price level away from being a stack
selling a balance but if you're just
looking for stack imbalances you're
gonna miss this that's why our software
will put a box around this the square
box around the candle so you know
going back number one has no sign of
balances number two has one cell
imbalance but it's number three that has
the three cell and imbalances right
there on the top at your swing high okay
so going back to your candlestick chart
can you see the imbalances no you can't
you don't see imbalances at all if
you're just looking at a normal
candlestick chart now let's start moving
into reversals right the simple rules
right in order to trade a reversal there
needs to be a clear directional move you
know sometimes people start looking for
a reverses when the market hasn't really
rallied or sold off you know in my
opinion you need a clear directional
move right and you need to have you need
to have hit a swing high or a swing low
and the market to start turning right to
market to start trading down off that
high or start rallying up off that low
then you're going to start looking
internally into the bar at supply and
demand and how you're gonna see that is
you're gonna see the imbalances you know
are people coming into the market to buy
off a low or come into the market to
sell off that high right and you're
gonna be looking in the bar for buying a
balance he's gonna be looking for blue
numbers inside the bar or red numbers
for selling imbalances inside the bar
now there's gonna be two types of
reversals I'm going to discuss now and
they're easy to spot in the order flow
so the first type these aggressive
traders coming in at a swing high or
swing low second type is trapped traders
basically want to break down or break
out fails both are easy to spot simply
by looking at imbalances in the order
flow okay so for the first type of
reversal I'm going to share with you is
the aggressive traders coming in at
swing highs or swing lows there's true
criteria I require for this trade number
one is a clear swing high or clear swing
low not a bar before or after the swing
high or low is made know that bar has to
be the low swing low and preferably I
like it to be the low by you know a few
few price levels right so if the
previous bar the low was seven
then our new swing low the bar is gotta
be like five preferably or four three
it's got to be much lower not much lower
but a little bit lower and I want to see
multiple three or more buying imbalances
for a buy at a swing low so I want to
see at least at at three price levels I
want to see aggressive buying appear
right and for a sell I want to see
multiple selling imbalances coming in
after the swing high is made in the bar
when you made the swing high so I want
you to see the bar make a swing high
then all of a sudden I want to see
sellers retract it to that high and come
in and start selling it I want to start
seeing you know three or more selling
imbalances in that bar so I'm gonna show
you a bunch of different charts okay and
I'll show you a minis crude euro
currency and buns now you know so many
people trade on so many different types
of charts you know if I don't cover your
chart you know I apologize but there's
only so many different ways you could
look at the market so I'm gonna show you
like a mainly find volume I will show
you the 30 second or 1 minute
some of the other markets I'm gonna show
you five minutes and even 15 minutes
people always ask can I use order flow
on a 15-minute chart so this is an e
mini 5,000 volume chart and again this
was last night or the night before
rather and again you know it's a 5,000
volume chart so it's not constricted by
time it's constricted by volume but what
I'm looking for like I got the arrows
here right you got your swing low clear
swing low you know much lower than the
previous bar but you're seeing buying
the balances coming in here right it's
got the pink box around the green candle
all right you got one two three four or
five six imbalances here on this first
low alright then the next bar straight
up next bar higher next bar higher again
it doesn't look like marching on and
grant and this markets been pretty
volatile but you know it's essentially a
move from around the 2412 area up into
you know the twenty four thirty area
then a little bit later you made a new
low right and then what do you have
you've got about eight
my imbalances coming in after that low
is made and then the next bar goes
literally from oh four all the way up to
you know twenty eight and again you know
in this type of market you really want
to get in and out as fast as you can
limit your risk you want to be looking
for quick trades you know and if the
next bar you know oftentimes you see
these next bars just explode on you in
the direction that you want to be you
know positioned in so here's a swing
high also a five thousand volume chart
again you hit your swing high you've got
seven selling imbalances coming in
market has a nice sell-off right here's
a swing low market in the next bar
didn't go higher than the first bar it
just went sideways for two bars you made
a new low by two ticks before it
exploded again to the upside about a
thirty point move there now people
always ask me where would I put my stop
normally I put my stop below the low of
the signal bar and normally I wait for
the next bar to open up and start
trading higher before taking a trade so
this this one is you know I wouldn't
take the trade because we didn't make
that move initially right I like the
market to start moving in my direction
faster but you know if you're one that
just you know people like to automate
things and take every single trade I
prefer to read the order flow because
it's going to benefit you over time you
know if you get longer than the market
puts in a red candle and test the low
that's probably not a good sign here you
did break the low buy two ticks before
turning around and rallying but you know
in this market environment having tight
stops sometimes is just going to stop
you out now this is not a buy or a sell
okay and why not because this is not a
clear this red bar right for getting
short it's not a swing high just as this
bar for getting long it's not a swing
low okay that's the criteria you know
that's why you know people say well I'm
looking for a reversal so you know this
red bar is the is the swing low and then
the next bar starts coming up
yeah yeah I I see that but that doesn't
meet the criteria all right if I'm
looking for a reversal bar this is not a
reversal bar right just as this other
one is not a reversal bar instead you
know it's an inside bar and you're not
even at a swing high in the bar before
it you know that's why you know you hate
to say you gotta follow the rules but
you know the rules are there to qualify
what you're looking at in the market
it's another example all right this one
you know this is a nice swing high okay
high the day but what happened to the
market self no it just went sideways
okay sometimes the best trading ideas
don't work out you know it just went
sideways okay that happens in trading
this is a nice nicer one you know this
is a clear low even though it's just
sort of been going sideways sideways
sideways but you did break and make a
nice clear low then you got your
multiple buying imbalances and then the
next bar rallies you know ten points now
excuse me this is a thirty second chart
okay so you know I have the arrow here
at this swing low right you got your
buying imbalances market made a nice
rally now people say Mike what about
this other one here okay it's a it's a
double bottom you know the first candle
down and then the second candle up they
got to share the same bottom
for a reversal I wouldn't at this point
really consider that reversal even
though this one had a nice little move
before coming down and sort of testing
the bottom again and making the big move
you know this is borderline right the
first one here with no arrow well you
have the green bar next to the red bar
but the second one is clear
I like clear trading signals now here's
one it just went sideways again made a
new high by a couple of ticks then had
the nice sell-off
you know again here you have a double
top where it didn't get the sell-off but
you know these things happen even if you
sold this right you get stopped out here
you got another signal to get short
hopefully you could have caught that one
now this is a 30 second chart again
right clear high multiple imbalances one
two three and I sell off from you know
the the 80s down into the 70s over the
next several bars alright so one minute
crude chart okay nice clear swing high
multiple selling imbalances at the
bottom of the bar it doesn't look like
much but this is about a 20 cent
sell-off in the next bar market then
just goes sideways on you before it
starts drifting down again so you've
seen it on 30 second chart 1-minute
chart
crude oil chart a mini chart euro
currency chart one-minute chart your new
higher the day multiple selling
imbalances market sells off about 20
ticks euro currency 5 minute chart this
time okay so you're expanding your time
horizon there's your multiple selling
imbalances at the high the market sells
off from the you know 109 20 area down
below
108 80
another 5-minute chart again your ma you
have clear high multiple selling
imbalances next bar you know from the
108 95 area just in the next bar to the
108 75 area 20 20 ticks in one bar okay
this is also a five-minute chart you
know some of these charts honestly they
start to look alike because you're
seeing the same things happen over and
over and over in the market here's a
five-minute chart of the euro currency a
sell at the swing high 108 20 goes down
to the 107 ATS then you got a buy signal
over here at this other at the swing low
again and the market goes up from the
108 you know Oh 500 ten area over the
next bar in the same bar to the one away
25 and then you know a couple bars later
two new highs now the next chart you
know people always ask me hey can I use
order flow on you know longer-term
charts
personally I don't but I know some
people that do right and that's why I'm
sharing this method with you of looking
for these multiple imbalances you're not
gonna see them very often on longer-term
charts but this is a crude oil 15-minute
chart you got your nice swing high here
rally up off the low got a swing high I
had a scrunch it so you're not seeing
the numbers but there's I know there's a
box around the bar so I know I got
multiple selling imbalances market
started to sell off you know they were
trading around 24 90
then it just goes a little bit sideways
then boom you get you know 130 you get
the big bar that's breaks from 2480 down
to 20 to 80 a $2.00 move right here but
it was signaled right here in this bar
with the multiple selling of balances
this is a five-year note it's a
15-minute chart this is your low of the
day coming up off your low the day
aggressive buyers are coming in now you
know in some of my courses I talked
about reading actually the actual
numbers in here there's something very
bullish in this bar with the divergence
with the ratio with the zero print with
the one print in there that's also very
bullish but you went from basically your
low of the day all the way back up to
the highs of the day okay it's a
15-minute chart so you know can you use
it on 15 minute charts yes you can I
think that if you're gonna watch
15-minute charts you need to expand you
know what you're looking at you get it
look at one more one or two markets
because you're not gonna get very many
signals some days you may get no signals
on a 15-minute chart
now this is a bunt a German bund 5
minute chart for you guys in Europe all
right your higher the day multiple
selling imbalances coming in and you got
a nice you know 50 tick sell-off here
again that's not a 5 minute chart
another 5 minute chart from your low of
the day you got your multiple buying
imbalances to your high of the day
multiple selling imbalances I think you
sell off from your high of the day I
mean it it appears over and over and
over so we'll bun to one-minute chart ok
your low of the day market it gradually
works higher you know it's not a big
dramatic rally up but you know after a
big sharp move down you know sometimes
the markets gonna struggle to put in a
rally in but at least it's going in the
right direction so that is the first one
you know so hopefully by now you can see
how easy it is to spot potential market
reversals by looking at the order flow
right I didn't make any calculations
other than seeing what the volume was
traded on the bid versus the volume
traded on the offer I didn't have to
draw any squiggly lines you know if
you're not using my
software you just have to look at your
chart and see do I see three or more
imbalances in the bar I think my chart
is nicer and that it will highlight it
to you I like to keep my charts nice and
clean right and that's the whole point
of trading is with order flows to keep
it clean right understand what's
happening in the market and apply that
so the second one that I'll talk about
today is the trap traders now what's a
trap trader it's a term you hear a lot
of people use nowadays it's basically
someone who's long and wrong bought at
the high of a move or short in the hole
which is you know someone who sold at
the low of the move basically when
traders get in at bad levels you know
we've all done that we've all bought the
high of the move we all sold the low of
them you know we also below then we
cover at the high you know unfortunately
it happens to me sometimes but that's
trading now in order flow analysis right
when you have three or more imbalances
stacked on top of each other that's
called stacked imbalance all right I
explained that a little earlier and
normally when you have three stacked
buying imbalances they appear in a green
up candle right because you have
aggressive buying as the market is
moving prices up conversely when you see
stacks on imbalances you see them in red
down candles because aggressive sellers
are active okay so for example right as
the markets moving down you see red
candles with stacked selling a balances
you see green candles as the market is
starting to go up with stacked buying
imbalances now what I wanna show you is
what happens when the opposite happens
right when you have stacks selling
imbalances in a green up candle right
when you have stacked buying imbalances
in a red down candle that is a result of
trapped traders traders who are late to
the party so to speak you know they get
in the market at bad levels usually
because they don't understand the
context in market structure or just
plain formal right fear of missing out
all the markets rallying I got to buy
markets on off I got a cell or I can't
take any more heat on this trader I got
to get out they buy the high I can't
take any more heat on this long trade
they get out they sell the low you know
that happens and
this happens at market turning points
why is because the last group of
aggressive buyer's or seller's has come
to the market you know there's a saying
you know someone has to buy the hi and
you know for older generation traders
when they were still people still read
the newspaper there was a saying right I
made print and what would that would
mean is if you bought the higher the low
of the day you know that's going to be
printed in the newspaper because you
know the news newspaper would show the
open high low close prices so if you
bought the high you'd say hey I made the
paper you know I made the print that was
buying a higher sell on the low so for
example right here's a market this is
Eve minis 1000 tick chart no markets
going up you can't really see it on this
edge here but you have a red candle at
this swing high it's like a double top
but you got big buying imbalances I mean
I got another chart here I'll show you
it's a little clearer it's the same one
all right you got the big buying
imbalances and then the market sold off
right a nice 20-point sell-off right
what's happening here is you know again
the market was going up started to come
off of Sun a big trader or a bunch of
little traders came in I got to buy you
know mark is going up I got to buy well
what happened is the supply and demand
paradigm shifted in this bar those guys
got long but at the same time they're
getting long all the big sellers are
taking this opportunity to get short at
these high prices and then the market
sold off right these guys here are
trapped now people would have you
believe they're trapped traders are like
a big quantity of traders often it's a
small quantity but you're gonna see it
in the imbalances and that's why looking
at the order flow it's gonna give you an
advantage over other traders that are
not looking at order flow so it's 1/32
emini chart 32nd in this market
environment 32nd versus a one-minute
chart is much better you know if you're
still looking at a one minute chart I
just try and take it down a little bit
because most people can't handle
that much heat you know most intraday
traders aren't gonna you know on a
1-minute chart you're looking at price
movements sometimes of you know five
hundred dollars by taking it down on a
shorter timeframe at least you're sort
of limiting that exposure a bit and you
can get in and out a lot quicker so here
you have a market rallied up right
you're coming up here making new highs
all of a sudden oh I got a buy right
these guys but get aggressive they buy
their 150 contracts but at the same time
they realize that it's time to buy all
the major sellers all the people with
supplier thinking hey this is nice high
price I got start selling these are the
people with Softsoap sitting in their
basement ready to sell you know cuz
price is high I could sell it now make a
nice profit what happens market sells
off over the next five bars and again
you know a lot of these charts they look
eerily similar is because this pattern
repeats over and over in the markets all
right honestly before all the volatility
exploded in the markets you'd see this
mainly on the more volatile markets like
dax like nasdaq even mini Dow
occasionally in crude but now you're
seeing it in a minis partly because of
the extreme volatility that we've been
experiencing in the last few months the
last few weeks again market rallies up
people oh my gosh I get long markets
rally I don't wanna miss this rally they
buy it here
wrong where I could start selling off
boom again another 15 20 point sell-off
on a 30 second chart it's a five-minute
euro currency chart okay
sort of going back and forth starts
coming down oh we broke her we broke our
low you know a lot of these price action
traders we broke this little guy get
short on Sun so they get short what
happens at the same time they're getting
short you know the the bigger traders
are realizing this is my buying
opportunity you know people say well
that's a stop run no this is people
getting short at bad prices because they
don't understand what's happening in the
market market makes it nice rally up
right even up here I don't have the
arrow but you got buying imbalances in
this red candle right not normally I
would prefer this red candle to be a
swing high but it's still important I'm
still looking at it because it's not
what you expect to see right what's
happening
you made this new high market came off a
little bit next bar opens up start
training a little bit higher aggressive
seller sorry I'm big passive sellers
came in offering it out but it's met by
the aggressive buyers you got that
buying imbalance but the aggressive
buyers ran out the bullets I think got
no more left to buy no more power to buy
but the aggressive sellers got a lot of
supply market sells off same thing here
crude one minute chart came down test
the slow boom trap traders start going
up more trap traders market makes a nice
fifty cent rally
and Smoove it on again understand
context right here you have trapped
Raiders but we're on a move up already
right you want to see if you're looking
to buy you know where people are gonna
be trapped it's gonna be at Lowe's right
if you're going to be looking at a swing
high you're not gonna be looking for
trapped buyers or sorry trap sellers
you're gonna be looking for trapped
buyers right so that's this is an
example of a trade not to take all right
you gotta understand market context now
here's one you know 30 second chart it
just went sideways you know I can say it
failed because honestly if if trades not
working out after a couple bars you'd
get out right so you get out as small
loss you know have to be married to it
30 second crude oil chart again just
sort of went sideways didn't really sell
off you know but that's what happens so
don't make trading more complicated than
it needs to be right you want to get
from point A to point B as fast as
possible all right a lot of people take
a lot of side tracks so hopefully by now
you can see how just using the
imbalances right and there's so many
other parts of order flow that you can
use but just imbalances give you amazing
trading opportunities all right you just
need to know what to look for and it
does help to have software that has the
ability to highlight it to you so if
you're interested in my software right
the software that we use to generate
these charts go to order flows calm
slash off to dot HTML and I got a
special price okay and this is just for
this weekend it's a one-time price of
just 675 normally the software by itself
is $8.99 but I'm also including my order
full trading course as well as my order
faux inner circle video series which is
an additional about 50 hours of training
is about 56 courses in there and for
this weekend until Sunday night you're
gonna be able to get it for just 675 now
there's no additional you know
indicators like the pulse or the turns
this is for people that really want to
get started in order flow and a good
footprint chart so just go to order
flows comm slash off the two takes you
to this page
just scroll down to the bottom here's
the button you can see the price there
you click on the button it takes you to
PayPal right I don't get your
information nothing like that is
processed by PayPal now if you're
interested in my book you go to order
Flo's calm a slash book you can download
it you just have to enter your name and
email and hit submit
right they'll take you to the digital
download page ok so you know I'm not
gonna email it to you afterwards it
appears after you enter your email so go
to order Flo's calm slash book to get my
book if you want to get the software go
to order Flo's calm slash off to dot
html' now again now this is a special
for new users right I know again we're
in a time of crisis a lot of people are
losing their jobs I lowered the price
specifically for new users so again this
is just a very limited time so anybody
that's interested you know now is the
time to to get it you know we're all on
lockdown
and you got a lot of time to study the
markets so Anna thanks for having me I
think I ran out of time for questions
but if anybody's got a question you like
just send me an email it's Mike thank
you so much Michael you can take 2-3
minutes to look for any questions that
you might meet let me see if I could see
anything very generous offer by the way
thank you so much
thanks well some of these questions I
don't really have time to get into them
right now because a lot of them is like
can you comment on this market comment
on that market but I tell you what if
anybody's got any question I don't want
to take anybody else's time just shoot
me an email it's my cat order Flo's calm
and I'll try to get back to you as
quickly as possible
alrighty by the way I would like to
announce that this Saturday at 10 a.m.
Pacific we are having with Michael a big
event one speaker event so Michael would
have a lot of time to answer your
questions yeah be sure to join that it's
going to be a nice nice
long one I want to cover a lot of stuff
that I haven't covered today or in any
of the recent webinars that we've done
okay thank you so much
all right bye-bye